[Music]
video games those words mean a lot to a
lot of different people to some a video
game is a unique way of storytelling
others play games for the competition in
camaraderie but no matter what camp
you're in it's impossible to ignore the
importance of gameplay in most cases a
game needs to be fun before anything
else it needs to feel good in the
players hands it's truly an art form and
sometimes it's an art form that gets
lost in the realistic graphics or dense
skill trees and progression systems I
recently played a top-down twin-stick
shooter that focuses almost solely on
gameplay called next machina due out in
2017
[Music]
based on what I played the game is
rather simple you jump from arena to
arena gunning down robots using the
right stick you have a special attack
and a dash but that's about it it only
takes seconds to get the hang of the
controls and within minutes next machina
had sunk its teeth in me soon I was
stringing together dashes and attacks
and formulating my own strategies on how
to survive each stage but as you'd
expect you can't just stick to one
strategy certain enemies have different
attack patterns that force me to
navigate the area in a way I hadn't
before much like resogun one of house
marks previous games timing my dashes
while slipping through enemy fire became
just as important as taking down the
opposition
but all this isn't new and how smart
where's its inspiration on its sleeve
robotron 2084 a game by Eugene Jarvis
was one of the first games to popularize
the use of twin joysticks and that came
out in 1982 a time when a good game was
one that played well and story and
presentation came second and robotron
2084 did just that the game is widely
considered one of the best arcade games
ever made and those who have fond
memories of Robotron 2084 or smash TV
will be pleased to know that this game
is being developed alongside Eugene
Jarvis next machina even shares a
similar premise to robotron 2084 robots
have taken over the world and mankind is
fighting back
so the premise is simple the controls
are simple and the mechanics are simple
those who played house marks last game
alienation might be a little
disappointed to hear this alienation had
loot customizable weapons and a deep
skill tree alienation felt more like a
Diablo twin stick shooter next machina
on the other hand favors a more arcadey
pick up and play style you won't be
showing off your loot to your friends
you'll be fighting them for high schools
but shedding complexity can also leave
the core of the game vulnerable imagine
an assassin's creed game but stripped
away the story progression and
exploration and left only the combat
that wouldn't be fun now that's an
extreme example but when you think about
a game like resogun or next machina the
game playing combat or all that's there
who's going to want to chase high scores
on a game that isn't fun well next
machina is really fun once you find a
rhythm it's intoxicating the fluid
gameplay paired with the sights and
sounds demanded my attention
[Music]
and I wasn't playing to unlock the next
level or to get a new weapon or perk I
was playing because the simple act of
playing was so damn funny obviously I
only got to see a small slice of the
full game and there could be an unlock
system or a skill tree it may even get
old after a few hours but what I can say
is that I can't remember the last time I
was so engrossed in a video game
Jarvis's and house marks idea behind the
game you probably guessed it by now is a
simple one Jarvis told house mark that
the reason humans and robots don't get
along is because humans strive for
perfection so they make robots to be
perfect while robots strive for
imperfection because they want to be
more like humans this strive for
perfection can be seen clear as day an
ex machina gameplay